ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูรินสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิง
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูเรียมวันนี้วันอะไร
คะวันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 16 ค่ะ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคม
ปีพตอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ค่ะ
ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ
2010  22 ค่ะแต่
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้บ่าย 15:00 น
นาทีนิ้ว
333 เลยนะคะใช่ค่ะ
ผู้หญิงชอบให้ 3 เหรอคะ
เม็ดชอบทะเลสาบไม่ดีค่ะผู้หญิงมีแฟนแล้ว
ก็มีอีกหนึ่งคนสามคนไม่ดีค่ะ
ว่าโรงแรมชอบเลขสัตว์
ไม่นะคะเตรียมชอบเลข 8 มากกว่า
แต่ว่า
08:00 น 88 ไม่มีนะคะไม่มีค่ะเสียใจมาก
เลยมี 8 โมง 88h
เสียงถ้าฟัง
1888 เนี่ยเวลาได้ฟังคำว่า 888 แหละคิด
ถึงไปห้องน้ำนะครับคุณเรียมผู้หญิงไม่ใช่
ถึงแบบแปลรถเหรอคะที่เราขับไปแล้วก็เป็น
แป้งๆ
แค่คูเรียมแต่อันนี้ของทุเรียนมัน
888 มันเออห้องน้ำหรือเปล่าเนอะไม่
ใช่ไม่ดีนะครับนี่แบบธรรมดาอยู่ไกลมาก
ผู้ชายค่ะผู้หญิงก็ชอบเอาฟางแล้วก็ต้อง
คิดไงใช่ไหม 9 ฟังเราก็คิด
หนูหนูดีมากค่ะผู้หญิง
ดีมากยังไงคะครูเรียมเพราะว่าวันนี้เรียง
จะพากรีนและนักเรียนมันเล่นเกม
หูฟังฟังๆแล้วก็คิด
โอโห้
ได้ค่ะครูเรียมแต่ว่าฟังอะไรคะ
ฟังพุ้นผู้ตอบ
ใช่ค่ะฟังเรียนพูดแล้วให้ครูหินกับนัก
เรียนตอบว่าเรียนกำลังพูดถึงอะไร
ได้ค่ะโห
คู่เรียมจะพูดกี่
กี่ข้อมันจะบอกบอกใบ้ใช่ไหม
คิดว่า
3 ข้อก็พอค่ะคุณหญิง
เออได้เลยค่ะครูเรียงผู้หญิงเพราะไหมคะ
พร้อมค่ะนักเรียนร้องไหมคะคิดว่านักเรียน
พร้อมเหมือนกัน
ดูหนังวิ่ง 2 อะไรคะ
เฟิร์สเปล่าทวีปมันได้ยินเสียงฝนตกที่
บ้านเลยนะจะไม่ตกก็เลย 2 คุยมองไม่เห็นนะ
คะว่าครูเรียนมีอะไร
มองทะลุอุสุไม่ได้
โอเคพร้อมนะคะครูเรียมเรามาเริ่ม
ข้อที่ 1 นะคะอ่ะอะไรเอ่ยที่ใช้มากๆตอนมี
โควิกนายที
อะไรเอ่ยที่ใช้มากๆ
ใช้บ่อยๆๆใช้ทุกวันหรออุ้ยผู้หญิงรู้แล้ว
อ่ะอะไรคะจะไม่รู้ถูกหรือเปล่านะคะหน้า
กากอนามัยไหม
ไม่ถูกค่ะ
ไม่ใช่น่าจะมีอนามัยไม่มีคำว่าไอ้อีกไหม
คะคำใบ้ที่ 2 ค่ะ
อะไรคะก็คือ
ทำให้สะอาด
ผู้หญิงสเปรย์แอลกอฮอล์
หรือ
หมายเพราะว่าสเปรย์แอลกอฮอล์เนี่ยเวลามือ
เราเนี่ยนี่ไม่สะอาดสกปรกแล้วก็
ฉีดสเปรย์แอลกอฮอล์แล้วก็
สะอาดใช่ไหมคิดว่า
ใกล้ถูกแล้วค่ะผู้หญิงเดี๋ยวว่ายังไม่ถูก
หรอก you แต่ว่ายังไม่ถูกร้อยเปอร์เซ็นต์
อ่ะ
อาจมีคำใบ้ที่ 3 ไหมคะคำใบ้ที่ 3 ค่ะใช้
มือหด
หนึ่งเกี่ยวอธิบายถูกมา
ใช้มือกดเร็ว alcohol นอนเหรอค่ะ
ผู้หญิงเก่งมาก
พูดแม่ตบริโกฮอลเซลล์โอเคไม่เหมือนกัน
โอเคได้ไม่เหมือนกันไงผู้หญิงก็ตอบถูก 50%
แต่ยังไม่ถูกร้อยเปอร์เซ็นต์
โอเค
เจลาสเปนส่ำเบสต้องใส่หมื่นกดแล้วก็ล้าง
มือให้สะอาดรอน้องนักเรียนตอบถูกไหม
เรื่องบอกว่าไม่รู้ตั้งแต่แต่ใบแรกแล้ว
ค่ะขี่เอ้านักเรียนอาจจะไม่ใส่ก็ได้นะ
มีอีกไหมคะมีอีกค่ะ
อะไรเอ่ยคิดตื่นเช้าขึ้นมาก็ต้องเจอเลย
ตื่นเช้าขึ้นมาก็ต้องเจอ
แปรงสีฟัน
ผู้หญิงทำไมแก่ผู้หญิงไม่คิดว่าเป็นแบบ
กระจกจะจบบ้างล่ะทำไมผู้หญิง
คิดอีกอะไรคิดถึงอ่ะผู้หญิงอะไรคิดว่า
กระจกกระจกครูก็คิดหน้าผู้เรียนวิทย์
กระจกกับแปรงสีฟันเต็มโต๊ะแปรงสีฟันดี
กว่าตัวอะไรผลิตกระจก
แรงสีฟันกระจกแปรงสีฟันจะเลือกอะไรดีแต่
คิดว่าเป็นกระเป๋าแปรงสีฟันแล้วก็ถูกใช่
ไหมใช่ค่ะถูกค่ะ
นักเรียนจะตอบถูกมันคือหญิงหรือเปล่าก็
ไม่รู้นะคะพี่เองนั้นอาจจะตอบกาแฟก็ได้
ตื่นตอนขึ้นมาแล้วเจอแฟร์
เราก็เดี๋ยว
คำต่อไป
อะไรกิน
อะไรเอ่ยใช้ตอนฝนตก
มั้ยตอนฝนตก
ไม่มี
ร่มให้
ต่อสู้ค่ะ na  and
Hell ลมหรอทำใบที่ 2 มีไหมคะคำไหว้ที่ 2
คืนทำให้ไม่เปียก
ไม่ใช่ร่มอ่ะอ่าอันนี้หรือเปล่า
เดี๋ยวเพื่อนนักเรียนไม่รู้จัก
ผู้เรียนบอกว่าอะไรผู้หญิงจะตอบอะไรและ
สิ่งไม่รู้ว่าถูกหรือเปล่านะคะนักเรียน
เสื้อกันฝน
ขอให้
ถูกต้องแล้วค่ะกริ่งเก่งมากเออเอ้า
เตรียมเวลาที่คอของที่ไว้ใช้เวลาฝนตกถ้า
ไม่ใช้ร่มก็เสื้อกันฝนฮะหมดแล้วก็ไม่น่า
จะถึงทำไมที่ 3 นะลืมก็ไม่รู้จะพูดอะไรนะ
คะ
มา
เรียมมีของอีกไหมคะมีค่ะเดี๋ยวครั้งนี้
เป็นสัตว์บ้างค่ะคุย
อ๋ออ๋อเป็นสัตว์
อะไรเอ่ย
ไม่มีค่ะขา
[เพลง]
อ่ะเฮ้อขา
นักเรียนตกแต่ง
นักเรียนคิดว่านักเรียนฟังภาษาไทยว่าไม่
มีขานักเรียนคิดว่านักเรียนเข้าใจแล้ว
เพราะกูหญิงตอบนกได้บอกหรือว่าเราเข้าใจ
ผิด
โอเคทำไมที่ 2
คำใบที่สองก็คือ
กินสัตว์
ก่อนนี้กินตัวอีกตัวนึงเหรอคะฉลามเหรอคะ
ฉลาม
ไม่ถูกค่ะกูอีกไม่ใช่ฉลาดไม่ใช่สไลม์ก็
ฉลามไม่มีขาแล้วก็ฉลามชอบกินกุ้งกินปลา
กินสัตว์ตัวอื่น
มีคำว่าไอ้ไหมคะไม่ใช่นี้ย่าจังเลยอ่ะอ่ะ
จะมีคำว่าไอ้ที่ 3 คำว่าให้ 3 ก็คือ
มีทั้งมีทิศแล้วก็ไม่มีพิษ
งู
นักเรียนคิดว่างงไหมคะ
งูงู
ถูกต้องค่ะงูงู
เตรียมเน็ตนะๆกับงูผู้หญิงเนี่ยเหมือนกัน
เลยมันจะอันนี้นั้นจะไม่มีพิษนะกัดแล้ว
ไม่ตาย
ก็มีงูที่มีพิษที่กัดแล้วก็ตาย
จ่ายตายนะคะหนูผู้หญิงผู้หญิงตอบได้ 4
ข้อแล้วอ่ะเก่งมากเลยมีอีกไหมคะมีอีกไหม
ค่ะมีอีกเยอะมากก็เลยค่ะแต่ว่าเราใช้เวลา
ไปไหนเท่าไหร่แล้ว
33 เตรียมกำลังคำนวณเวลาอยู่ยังยังมี
เวลาไลน์ยังไม่มี
เวลา
ถ้าอย่างนั้นไปคำคำที่ 5 ค่ะ
หน้าคำที่ 5 ก็คือ
0 สูงสุขสันต์เป็นสัตว์เหรอคะครูเรียม
ไม่ใช่สัตว์ค่ะ
อ๋อเป็นอะไรก็ได้ใช่ไหมสู่สูงอะไรเอ่ยสุข
หมู
สูงตึก
Apartment  Condominium
คอนโดมิเนียม
ไม่ใช่
อ้าว
ไม่ใช่แล้วทำใบที่ 2 อะไรคะ
คำใบที่สองก็คือ
อยู่ข้างถนน
ถ้าหนู
มีถนนที่เราขับรถถนนแล้วก็อยู่ข้างๆถนน
เสาไฟหรอคะ
เสาไฟ
ผู้หญิงให้ดู
เอาเมื่อไหร่จะเปิดได้แล้วคะเนี่ย
คิดว่าตอบเราไป
เสา Bike เสาไฟอันนี้นะคะนี้นะคะเสาร์ไป
อันนี้ไม่ใช่นะนิดเซเว่นใช่ไหมคะใช่เสาไฟ
ไหมคะเสาไฟสูงแล้วก็อยู่ข้างถนนประเทศไทย
ถูกต้องค่ะผู้หญิง
มีเสาไฟ
เสาไป
เราเฒ่าเกรียมใบเก่งผู้หญิงถ้า
ต้องการคำใบที่สามผู้หญิงจะคิดว่าต้องไป
ว่าอะไรอันเนี้ยถ้าเกิดผู้หญิงตีนกทำไม
อ้วนอีก
หรอหรือผู้หญิงก็จะคิดทำไมว่าประเทศนัก
เรียนเนี่ยอยู่ใต้ดิน
ของ
[เพลง]
ประเทศไทยนะอยู่ข้างถนน
ถ้าเกิดผู้หญิงใบ้ว่ามีนกลมก็อาจจะผู้
หญิงงงยังงงมากเลย
อะไรมีน้องเอ้าเพศไปประเทศไทยเสาไฟชอบมี
นกบินมาเกาะอ่ะพี่มาเกาะที่สอบไฟ
คิดตอบถูก 5 ข้อแล้วอะต้องมีอีกไหมคะคือ
ต้องหาอะไรยากยาก
ไปค่ะออกยักษ์ดาษมาผู้หญิงตอบถูกหมอก็เลย
ไหมใส่ใช่ผู้หญิงตอบหรือข้อเอาคำต่อไปดี
กว่าที่ค่ะ
คิดว่าครูหญิงเปิดและปิดทุกวันอะไรเอ่ย
ที่ครูหญิงเปิด
และปิดทุกวัน
มานี่หรอ
ไม่ถูกไปไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ไฟไม่ใช่สัตว์คุณ
เวลาแกคืน 18:00 น 19:00 นก็มีสวิตช์ไฟ
แล้วก็เปิดปิดทุกวันไม่ใช่ไฟหรอคำใบที่ 2
อะไรคะ
ทำไปที่สองก็คือฝัน
ตู้เย็น
ใช่ไหมผู้หญิงเกาะติดทุกวันปิดทุกวัน
เนี้ย
จะให้ๆให้ชมใบที่ 2 อะไรคะคำใบ้ที่สองก็
คือผู้หญิงเดินทาน
ผู้หญิงเดินผ่านเปิดปิดเปิดปิดทุกวันแล้ว
ก็เดินผ่านด้วย
ประตู
อะไรนะ
ผู้หญิงเก่งอ่ะผู้หญิงไม่คิดเป็นอย่าง
อื่นบ้างหรอ
ตกใจแล้วบางวิ่งฝนตกอะไรคะกับตุ๊กกูเรียน
บอกว่าเดินผ่านใหญ่ที่เดินผ่านประตูทุก
วันแล้วก็เปิดปิดก็เลยคิดอ่ะประตูอ่ะ
ก็
ต้องมีคดีอีกนักรู้เรื่อง
นี้ยากเลยค่ะเอาที่กูเรียนคิดว่าครูหญิง
แหละต่อไม่ถูกแน่ๆอ้า
ย่าสนเดียวมากๆโอเคคำต่อไป
อะไรเอ่ย
คนไทยไม่ชอบ
เรื่องที่ไปแม่
คิดว่าคนไทย
เซ็นคนรึเปล่า
The  Sick คนได้ไหมคะไม่ใช่ใครหนึ่งความ
ไม่ใช่มิสเตอร์เอมิสเตอร์บีไม่ใช่ใช่ไหม
เออไม่ใช่ค่ะครูหญิงเหมือนผู้หญิงจะมี
เค้าต่อยนะคะถ้าเกิดเป็นมิตร araya และ
กระบี่ผู้หญิงคิดออกเลยนะคะ
ติดออกจะ
คนไทยไม่ชอบ
ชีสต์
ชีสต์ผู้หญิงไม่ชอบชีสเหรอคะ
เพราะมีคนไทยหลายคนไม่ชอบชีสไงคนใช่ไหมคะ
ใช้ฉีดยาไม่ใช่ค่ะพี่เอกไม่ใช่นักเรียน
ฟังแล้วนักเรียนฟังแล้วโปรดแล้วนะคนไทย
ไม่ชอบชีส
โอเคไปคำว่าที่ 2 ดีกว่าทำไมที่ 2 อะไรคะ
ยิ่งตอนเที่ยงเนี่ยหยิบตอนเที่ยงก็ยิ่ง
ไม่ชอบเลย
[เพลง]
ดวงอาทิตย์หรอดวงอาทิตย์หรอคะ
ถูกฆ่า
นี้ไมคนไทยไม่ชอบดวงอาทิตย์
ร้อนได้ไหมไอชอบใช่ยิ่งตอนเที่ยงก็ยิ่ง
ไม่ชอบของมันร้อนมาก
ก็มันร้อนมากๆ
ถ้าจะนักเรียนอาจจะชอบใช่ไหมจริงหรอนัก
เรียนชอบจริงๆหรอคะไม่รู้เหมือนกันค่ะ
เห็นเมื่อก่อนนักเรียนเมื่อก่อนพ่อเวลา
ประเทศไทยตอนตอนประมาณตอนเที่ยง 13:00 น
แล้วเรียนชอบเดินไปที่ลุมพินีสวนลุมแล้ว
ก็พรหรือว่านักเรียนมาทะเลประเทศไทยในก็
ไม่นอนอาบแดด
แต่เวลาเกินที่อายุว่านักเรียนสอบคนไทย
เห็นแบบชาวต่างชาติมานอนอาบแดดผู้หญิงรู้
สึกยังไงอ่ะ
ไม่รอร้อนเหรอคะ
รู้สึกผู้หญิงอ่ะอ่า
วีดีโอดำน้ำเดี๋ยวดำนะไม่เอา
ใช่คนไทยก็เถอะ
คนไทยนี่ใส่หมวกนะคะการร่มใส่เสื้อแขนยาว
ใส่หน้ากากใส่แว่นตานี้คนไทยนะกลัวดวง
อาทิตย์มากๆร้อน
ใช่ค่ะหนูผู้หญิงตอบจริงแล้วนะ
ไม่รู้ว่านักเรียนตอบถูกกี่ข้อ
หรือว่าเรียนถูกคำใบ้ที่ 1 คำใบ้ที่ 2 คำ
ใบ้ที่ 3
โดยเฉพาะคำสุดท้ายเนี่ยที่เรียงบอกว่า
เรียนบ่อค่ะเรียงบอกว่าคนไทยไม่ชอบก็ไม่
รู้ว่านักเรียนยึดถึงพระอาทิตย์หรือเปล่า
ไม่รู้เหมือนกันนะ 3
กไก่ค่ะหรือว่านักเรียนคิดว่าอะไรที่คน
ไทยไม่ชอบชีสเหมือนผู้หญิงไหม
หรือว่าถ้านักเรียนชอบให้ครูเรียนกับผู้
หญิงเล่นเกมแบบนี้นะคะก็กดไลค์คลิปนี้
ด้วยนะคะ
ๆค่ะค่ะน้องครูเรียงก็ผู้หญิงก็ได้รู้ก็
นักเรียนชอบเล่นเกม
ถ่ายแล้วจะได้จะว่าคลิปวีดีโอนี้เนี่ย
จ่ายค่ะแต่ว่าคลิปวีดีโอนี้เนี่ยหมดเวลา
แล้วใช่ไหมคะครูเรียมใช่ค่ะผู้หญิงวันนี้
เราสองคนก็ต่างๆไปแล้ว
เจอกันยามใดแล้วนะคะนักเรียนค่าสวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะผู้หญิง
สวัสดีค่ะดีค่ะบ๊ายบางนึงอย่าคิดอะไรเอ่ย
เหมือนอื่น
ผู้หญิงก็พูดเลียมส์
[เพลง]